We've simplified terms by combining
factors within them, and we've combined
like terms. So, let's try to do both of
those things at the same time. Here, we
have a very long expression, 15x squared
plus 3x to the 7th minus 7x times 2x minus
4 times 2x minus 5 times 4 plus x times 3.
That took a really long time to write and
a really long time to say. So it would be
awesome if we could simplify this. That is
what I would like you to try to do. Now if
this looks daunting, no big deal, just
give it a try. You have absolutely nothing
to lose. Writing your work on paper first
will definitely help you. Also, remember
to try to simplify within each term first,
and then once you've done that, to
identify what the like terms are in this
expression, then you can work on combining
them together. Good luck.